Dennis Haysbert back heaven deposit
tones at Dennis's bit dulcet tones do
radio ever try that you know know in
discs I always wanted to act I went to
act since I was 10 years old who is the
one that you grown up saying you know
what I want to be like no God there was
so many uh Sydney of course what here
Sydney put here I'm sorry
his name you're talking to people here
like you could name any any any more
than any Sydney in sports the probably
okay Sydney Poitier that's enough
honest-to-goodness I had these three
guys on my wall along with Spyder
Lockhart and like football heroes okay
and and that was branda and Sir Laurence
Olivier okay
and so you had the Brando sir Laurence
Olivier and I swear it I swear on a
stack of Bibles man that had no idea how
famous these guys were except I loved
them sure because every nobody in my
family was into you know movies and
theater in that way and the movies I saw
of them and the movies I had liked were
turned out to be classics so I knew and
then yeah I played football baseball
ran track and get all that stuff you
know so Spyder Lockhart and Laurence
Olivier oh man I used to I want to say I
want it to be an inner filled defensive
that deep well you would have been I
mean you're how tall your Explorer
that's like Mel Blount I pretty much oh
yeah I probably would have moved to
safety probably just so you could come
downhill and yes yeah guys used to make
fun of me for being and acting so I get
him in practice because I was a
defensive game so you were you were
rushing the passer and I guess what
you're saying oh yeah I used to put rib
cages on my locker what do you mean
because that's where I used to hit them
here so you put rib cages on your locker
and a stamp oh you know because I used
to wipe out quarter dogs and what was
your baseball game like my baseball game
actually when baseball game was pretty
good but I
I couldn't I didn't play in high school
played by recreational league and Babe
Ruth okay
a nice pitch pitch so what was your
pitching game I've seen game was pretty
good I mean I think you know that was a
heavy ball I didn't know I had no idea
what a house that was throwing ah but
people used to say man you got a heavy
ball so when you we're watching you
swing in major league as Pedro Cerrano
yeah is that your swing that's miss 100
and I don't know if we ever talked about
this okay every ball I hit out mm-hmm I
hit out except not as far as they shot
it out because they have to reverse the
cameras hold on a second Dennis Haysbert
how many how many home runs did you hit
well I can age well I hit three in the
movie right I think it's being live I
hit every one of my head out okay and
all the batting practice you you oh yeah
oh yeah used to routinely so were you
the best hitter of all the actors I
would say so Charlie and I were the only
guys that could really play baseball and
Wesley was really athletic okay and
could run but wasn't he couldn't hit but
you but could Charlie had a rage he was
just truncated and Charlie could pitch
but you went yard more than anybody else
in the cast of major league except for
the other guys of the baseball guys
they're out there so who was the worst
okay phone works Corbin Bernsen could he
Corbin was okay I think Tom Tom Berenger
was like I love you Tom were you
superstitious as well are you as are you
a superstitious guy not really but I
realized how superstitious baseball
players are that is note of that there
is no doubt I mean I used to have a lot
of guys come up to me said you know we
used to play this movie on the bus going
to the game and ice you know set
firecrackers off on my bet on our bats
to you know the way come up did anybody
have rum today I'm gonna incorporate
they started using that a lot of guys
that they've started baseball players so
yeah do you have
Dennis Haysbert here on the Rich Eisen
show do you have any artifacts from the
film anywhere he's finally got a job
Udall I don't have the original because
I wanted to get rid of that because you
know that was voodoo
I was practicing and I said you know
what certain things you got to leave on
the set you know and somebody took that
and I don't know where they are now
because I haven't heard from them again
right so they took a voodoo doll and I
say okay I have a facsimile you have a
facsimile of Jobu here on the Rich Eisen
show dennis haysbert so are you are you
deep down warrior fan review cotton did
you vomit deep down Bay Area okay in
England following the warriors warriors
joining forever
you know I'm a bit of an enigma as far
as baseball's concerned because I'm a
baseball I mean a giant fan and a Dodger
fan which is crazy yes there's a good
reason for I get the floors yours first
of all Branch Rickey and Jackie Robinson
if we did have those two guys who
wouldn't have baseball as we know it and
that's not your fault everybody should
be a Dodger fan for them no matter what
team you root for hmm Dodgers should
have a nice place in your heart have you
posited this to any Giants fan
understand okay because I'm gonna talk
to this order a lot because I have
season tickets to the Dodgers okay
wish I had season tickets to the Giants
but I would you know I would probably
never see a game because I'm here here
you working and then working you're
working math but I've you know I've told
Tommy I said hey you know still giant
fan he's just really I said yeah but I'm
a Dodger fan I'll tell you why
and I give him that explanation he says
yeah I can understand that yeah who can
argue with you on that front I
understand that it's Hatfields and
McCoys when it all comes down to it yeah
I mean whenever I whenever I'm watching
the Giants you know play come in and
play the Dodgers I'm very quiet
you're now seeing some all-time great
stuff though I mean certainly since
Auckland is about to lose the Raiders
and they were also about to lose the
Warriors too and that though that the
City of Oakland is gonna have another
parade going down three out of four
years this is a this is as dynastic as
any I mean I've got a list right here
Patriots and Cowboys won three out of
four that's it you know in the NFL NFL
is going to make out like a bandit
moving the team to Las Vegas but that's
the only people that I believe that are
going to be successful with it I think
the fans are going to suffer you know
the big biggest part of the Raiders is
their tailgating mmm they won't be able
to tailgate in in Vegas and also I have
a real big problem with you know not so
much to gambling but the partying what
do you mean well you know you got you
know you have all these NFL teams
they're gonna be pouring in there every
weekend mm-hm like I said it's gonna be
great for the NFL cuz that you know the
revenue is just gonna pop excuse me it's
okay and but you know they better get
some counseling for those players well I
mean get them off the strip I'll tell
you what though I mean business trip the
NFL unlike baseball is some of them
teams will come in on Saturday and
they'll probably stay way the hell off
that strip and then bust their team in I
would imagine some sort of strict rules
than is that I hope so but you know what
are you gonna do for you you know when
you're the the Raiders and you got a
lift there that's another thing I don't
even know I say this all these people
who I know that live in Vegas or work
there I don't know how the hell that you
do it I know it'd be like you know
living in an amusement park all the time
you know sometimes you know maybe after
a while you just you know don't ride the
roller coaster it reminds me at the
Steely Dan song you know lost wages
Dennis Haysbert here on the Rich Eisen
show reverie with those who have not
caught it yet what do you like about it
what should what should people watch
revery for on NBC sir
you know because we're
going there that's that's gonna be a
reality very soon you know you got the
euro ray got the glasses and virtual
reality virtual reality glasses and the
first person you know shooter things and
you can get lost in that now imagine
when they put you know a chip in you and
you can just reappear in a space like
this and this is probably one of the
best spaces I've ever baby inflamed
either Thank You Dennis this place
appreciate that and the putting green
gosh we love having here you know I have
to come back maybe season I mean episode
pie you got it you know give you guys an
update just pop back in and in your
virtual reality world you know but
unintended consequence of getting into
this virtual reality world is you're
getting stuck people are getting stuck
because they don't want to come out
they'd rather be in the VR world in the
real world and and I think that's gonna
be a problem in the future
10:00 p.m. Eastern every Wednesday night
with you in it and like I said you're
welcome back anytime you want Matt it's
always fun having you here it's always
fun being here seems like every time you
hear the Warriors win it all so I'm sure
you want to come back any time
can't help it good to see a Dennis
Haysbert at Dennis Haysbert on Twitter
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience